eric bakarak covers the titans for the
tennessean
and he joins us now eric what's the
latest with the game this weekend
between the titans and the bills
dan i think everything is very much
firmly up in the air at this point i
think
everything is on the table you know i
still think that a forfeit
is is probably unlikely um
you know there's a few reasons for that
uh number one it costs
everyone money it costs the nfl it costs
you know not only the titans but but the
bills players their game checks
uh would be void if that were to happen
uh
you know it's unfair to the steelers i
think does that game the game that got
rescheduled last week
does that game also uh become forfeit
now that um you know this
upcoming game has been forfeit so
there's a lot of sort of ripple effects
that
that come into play with that um you
know i i don't think
uh as we stand here now there's any way
that the game gets played
as scheduled sunday noon just again with
another positive test this morning times
i've had
23 uh since september 24 uh eight of the
last 10 days they've returned at least
one positive test so i
right now i don't think there's any way
that game gets played as schedule on
sunday
is the nfl in town investigating the
titans
yes they've been in town since friday
since
last friday investigating the titans
that on that
investigation as of this morning to my
knowledge is ongoing
obviously they were looking into the
incident that that kind of came to light
yesterday first reported by paul
kaharski about the the titans meeting at
a private
school in the nashville area it was
about 15 players
that was on september 30th last
wednesday which would have been a day
after the team facility closed
um and the outbreak first came to light
eight positive tests the day before
those those players met
and i just had a leak source confirmed
that the titans were informed that day
that
uh in-person activities were prohibited
them and the vikings were both told that
you know so fines uh potential draft
pick losses you know
penalties are coming those are coming
down the pipeline at some point you know
whether
whether or not you know the nfl finds
more again that that's only one instance
that the nfl is looking into
all of that kind of remains to be seen
and we'll see if that leads to a forfeit
to me again that
that eventuality seems unlikely do we
know
are there marquee players who have
tested positive or may
be held out of this game if they played
i i know you know we're not a
hipaa laws and all of those things but i
i don't know
first it was a long snapper and it felt
like it was a backup and
people in the you know management but i
i don't know how how deep does this go
with that roster have
has anybody found out yeah so as every
day
the the titans are required to place the
the players that tested positive on the
covet 19 list
so that happens every afternoon around 3
30
or 4 30 eastern so to this point there's
been five starters
including the two top defensive lineman
jeffrey simmons daquan jones
yesterday corey davis uh their number
two receiver
was placed on the covet 19 list for a
positive test they also have adam
humphries and
bo brinkley the lawn snapper would also
be included in that list of starters
uh you know so that's that's obviously
substantial but anyway you slice it
taking 13 players away from a team
you know which to this point is the list
um you know
there's there's no way to go into a game
and kind of just be
prepared with that many guys missing we
spoke with mike grebel earlier this week
and he indicated that
you know the only way to make this work
from a numbers standpoint is to get
practice players uh practice squad
players involved on game day so
um you know even if this you know let's
say the game is pushed back to monday or
tuesday which would
you know cause a ripple effect with with
the uh the bill scheduled game for next
thursday against the chiefs
um you know you would still think that
most if not all of those players are
still absent
and uh you know that that would be a
severe
handicap on the titans for sure yeah but
also
you know what it's doing to these other
teams i think the nfl's got to look at
this and say all right we're going to
let the titans dodge a bullet we'll
reschedule the game with the steelers
now this time around and if there's a
possible impact on
you know other teams here i think you
know the nfl's got to crack down pretty
hard on the titans here and i i
that's why i wouldn't be surprised
there's a forfeit just to say
we don't want to have a situation happen
like baseball where the marlins
went willy-nilly and the cardinals did
too and nearly shut down the season for
a while so
i i don't know i i think that you're in
some dangerous territory here when it
comes to the impact
on these other teams that have you know
done it the right way
yeah absolutely and honestly then if you
go back to
the saturday before the titans week
three game against the vikings that
that's when shane bowen
the outside linebackers coach who's kind
of been a de facto defensive coordinator
for the titans this year they don't have
a
defensive coordinator by title that's
when he first tested positive
and you know he's the outside
linebackers coach again
de facto defensive coordinator he's you
know in the mix with a lot of players a
lot of team personnel
he was the only one that didn't travel
with the team to minnesota that that
game
um so you would think you know with
contact tracing and all that some some
players maybe should have stayed back
to avoid this to prevent you know the
spread
of the spread any further you know we've
seen that the vikings return no positive
tests which is good
but again it kind of just goes back to
to contact tracing
the incubation period for this thing
which you know the cdc says is 14 days
which
you know we're coming up on that now
theoretically the next couple days we
could also see a few more positive tests
so
i just think any way you slice it it's
it's a total nightmare scenario for the
titans and the nfl
eric great stuff we appreciate you
joining us and uh we'll keep an eye on
what you're reporting thank you
thanks dan that's eric bakarak he covers
the titans for the tennessean